Now that we've seen what
an orthographic camera can do for
us, let's see how to create,
manipulate, and apply one.
In this demo, we've got a game world
with a huge star, a tiny planet, and
an itty bitty satellite.
Let's see what this looks like,
without using a camera.
Using the default camera, we can just
barely see the edge of the star.
We can see just half the planet.
And we can't even see the satellite.
It's actually right here, but it's so
small, it's not even one pixel wide.
So, let's use an orthographic camera
to zoom in on each one of these
objects in turn.
So, what is a camera?
Well, camera holds on to two matrices.
One matrix encodes the camera's position
and orientation in the game world.
For 2D games, this is usually kist a
simple x, y pair, but for 3D games, say,
a 3D flight simulator, the camera can
hold the plane's 3D position, its pitch,
its roll, and its yaw.
The other matrix encodes how the camera
translates positions in the world
into positions on the screen.
This includes how much
perspective to include,
that's fisheye lens
versus telephoto lens.
And how big an area on the screen
the camera will ultimately draw to.
To use a camera, we first need
to declare and initialize it.
Then there are two things we have
to do down in the render callback.
The first is calling camera.update.
Whenever we adjust the properties of
a camera, like its position, it needs to
fold those changes into the matrices
that define how it looks at the world.
The easy way to ensure this happens
is just to call update each frame.
It's a fast operation, so no worries.
The second thing we need to
do is tell our shape renderer
that we want to use our camera.
We do this by setting the shape
renderer's projection matrix to
the camera's combined matrix.
The combined matrix is the culmination
of the camera's view and
projection matrices.
Yeah, there's a lot of
matrices flying around.
Basically, shapeRenderer doesn't have a
notion of position in some larger world,
so all it's got is a projection matrix.
One more thing is we need to
handle screen resizing correctly.
The resize callback gets
called right after create and
any time the screen size changes.
Which could be because
a mobile device rotated, or
because we're running
the desktop app and
the user is changing the window
size by dragging around the corner.
When the screen size changes, we need
to make sure our camera is updated.
If the camera thinks that the screen
is smaller than it really is,
shapes will be way bigger than we
want them to be, and vice versa.
This call setToOrtho updates
the camera with the new screen size.
The first argument is whether
an increase in value of
y should mean going down the screen and
we don't want that to be true.
All right,
let's see what code it'll take
in order to get the camera to zoom
in on each of these objects in turn.